[Applause]
that was my mistake
[Music]
it's Halloween it's the best time of
year everybody knows it today we're not
scary farm to become monsters and crawl
around in fog and scare people we're
gonna put on some effects makeup and
costumes and become another person
entirely and for the try guys it's gonna
really bring out our inner demons my
name is John Cooke I am an entertainment
designer here for Knott's Scary Farm we
hire about a thousand people in and we
transform them into monsters we teach
them everything we put them in their
costumes makeup dude get everything
ready and we lead them through the
charge get them out there and just
terrifying people how does one become a
monster not only do you have to apply
for a normal job then we come down we
put you through the wringer we ask you
guys that tenure Satan ordering the
coffee and we just see how you do I
don't like this at all apparently Ned is
a big old baby super afraid of haunted
houses I'm always like hey try guys
let's go watch a horror movie
Zak goes yeah Keith goes all right I got
nothing else to do and that goes oh is
it rain it isn't there
or however I do have a theater
background I think I'll be great with
coming up with character getting into
the physicality of it doing weird voices
my goal today is to get through this
without getting scared
you know I'm such a friendly guy it's
tough for me to make people sad and
upset I think Keith is just gonna have
so much fun my goal is to be the most
unique monster anybody's ever seen in a
teen part and I want them to scream so
loud that they also fall in love this is
honestly a dream come true for me I'm
like so giddy I cannot control it
Zak loves dark and I'm rooting for him
to really step up his game and be bigger
than his actual body I'm not a scary
person
I've never intimidated anybody in my
life so my goal today I wanna scare
somebody I want to see you like when I
get in all the makeup can I inhabit a
character can I scare some people the
way that I never get to in real life I
feel like everyone says you put a
costume on during October for me the
other 11 months that's what I'm wearing
my costume my good costume Eugene is
kind of like a demon literally a demon
I'm most excited about getting in touch
with the inner crazy Halloween demon
that I know has resided within me ever
since I was a child I really want to
terrorize as many people as possible so
that they never forget my demon face so
how do we turn these four beautiful boys
into four terrifying monsters oh I don't
know do we even need masks
okay John I'm gonna go through that the
transformation process won't get you
fitted with some costumes we're gonna
put you in some shirts and some dusters
and vests okay there you go
well you never liked twinsies yeah I
cannot show up to ghost town in the same
outfit is looking at us how would you
think we should be crafted into monsters
well ghost town not scary farm is where
it started we are looking for a dead
decayed ghost town citizens the story is
that the Greenwood cursed people into to
roam the streets of calico as half-human
half-animal hybrids she cursed the town
of ghost town and every year at
Halloween time we return we have
monsters that returned year after year
like something I've been here for 20
plus years and those seem to be the ones
that develop their character the most
they build their own costumes and those
become the icons we were gonna become
monsters do you have any advice for us
it comes from in here it's more than
just putting on a cost to put out some
nice prosthetic appliances and then
we're gonna do all the makeup
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
three-two-one Oh hahaha I'm amazing I'm
horrifying I'm so I'm a monster it's
what I've always wanted
Oh God look at that oh look at all those
teeth I think I'm just gonna be really
excited to meet people but I think I
might accidentally scare him away
I'm really out there to make friends
tonight I look kind of like a kpop star
got murdered
I think yeah you're definitely scariest
I'm the only truly scary one here I love
it I love it I love it
never take never change you're beautiful
you're scary I'm ready for school
yeah the blood almost makes it look like
got a dye job but a diee job get it it's
a pun guys meet the pros and you're
gonna give us your best monster noise
okay we do kind of a catwalk thing we're
gonna see your best monster movements
all right all right there you go what
scares somebody's combination of sound
and movement so let's get those quick
those quick startles what about the
sliders the sliders let me have these
guys that that go out the glue all this
metal to them they put on kneepads and
they just run and slide and it's a very
very cool effective thing that's a big
thing that started here at Knott's Scary
Farm
so three main rules guys rules of scare
ready no touching no dirty talk no foul
language
duping Comcast kids and don't break
character okay my life ready to tear
some guests up let's go
[Music]
so what the who's that yeah this is a
lot tougher people are really hard to
scare how people act like they're not
afraid the quarter the people try to
heckle you it's really really hard to
actually get a scream I am sweating
through everything I'm exhausted turns
out it takes a lot of work it's really
hard work I throw it already hurts keeps
his head storytimes all the kids had a
little powwow with some kids had a
little story time
honestly that was a failure because I
didn't know what to do with all of them
I got them on the ground I'm like well
now and now what I don't know I know
that you hear those screams
those are screams of joy those are
screams dang thank you try guys for
scaring the [ __ ] out of me
what was so great was working with the
other try guys and discovering our demon
[ __ ] personalities
my demon child he's silent he's creepy
and he follows you like a rain clouds
really like being a decoy cuz I could go
and just kind of like get someone's
attention and someone could scare him
from behind
I got a few really good slides and some
really nice scares to ah I I don't know
if I was actually the scariest but I
think a lot of people are gonna remember
me we learned an important lesson here
today don't challenge Ned to be a creepy
[Music]
I kind of felt a little I mean she was
almost crying I made a girl cry I feel
so bad well this was an absolute dream
come true or was it a nightmare same
exact thing happy Halloween
[ __ ] this was so fun I don't
know I don't know what I was scared of
everybody here is just having fun what a
job this is it's wonderful you don't
think about it but it's such a team
effort all these amazing makeup artists
costume designers set designers it's
theater like this is straight-up theater
to be out here with the people to see
how much work goes it was a total honor
and I'm glad that we could be a part of
it thank you so much to Knott's Scary
Farm and all the wonderful people who
work for it until next time happy
Halloween
I take my coffee like I take my souls